[Music]
when I choose an opening or a defense
and I start to think about it a lot of
thoughts go through my mind
for example I'm always always wherever I
go I'm asked the question how do i
improve how do I get better what books
would you recommend what can I do to
speed up my learning process all of
these things well I don't really have
the answers so much as I can share with
you the experiences I've had so one of
the things we need to do is very
carefully think about the openings we
choose if we choose the movie four
before we even choose the movie four we
have to understand that this is what
most likely the oldest move in chess and
therefore the most well mapped move in
chess in other words if our opponents
are competent too good to even excellent
players they're going to have a
specialized system against 1.e4 so we
have to anticipate that not only must we
have a very very broad knowledge of a
large number of defenses that even we
should have something for any type of
defense we might get hit with we might
get hit with a French defense we might
get hit with an Alekhine's we might get
hit with a Scandinavian a classical be
five we might get hit with a perk we
might even get hit with an English kind
of system the George st. George st.
George variation a six be fine a
Sicilian in other words there are a lot
a lot a lot of openings
we could come up against and the same
for d4 and so on so one of the things
that I like to stress to people who were
in my shoes of coming up and trying to
improve their play and understand how
they could become better players more
rapidly is to think about the opening
choices they make and to look at the
opening choices they make as well as
their defenses from what I call the
skeletal point of view in other words
the pawn structure yeah
so how many of you play the French
defense how many of you who play e4 have
played against the French defense okay
well the French defense is stiff I'd buy
the movie six d4 d5 and E five this is
basically the French defense structure
yes how you get here then that the
knight may have be here the knight may
be here this of course is called the
advanced French defense with E 5 on move
three but the essence is that we have a
pawn structure in the center it looks
like this it's fixed in fact the pawns
are locked up so if we were going to
play this position for white or for
black what I would be doing is I would
be removing all the pieces all the
pieces off the back leg but I would be
looking from the position of the pawn
skeleton that is to say there's only
eight pawns on the board and when I look
at the pawn skeleton it really helps me
try to understand simple things in other
words I say the pawn structure is going
to tell you what you have to do so if we
just include pardon me just for the
moment
two other moves we have c5 c3 and if we
were just to continue I'm not saying
that Fon takes pawn takes is the right
way but if we just were to take a look
at this structure there's a few things I
would say to myself well what do I like
about the structure for white or
conversely what do I like about the
structure for black Michael yes you
could vary
yes exactly a very very good point that
you could do the advance and try to get
some space on the queenside no question
and in fact we'll come right back to
that for a moment what I like to do is I
like to look at the potential middle
game plans the potential middle game
plans based just on the skeleton so the
first thing I do when I look at the
position like this I said well the only
open file is a C file very very simple
I'm gonna put my rook on c1 just bring
my work on c1 I like white space I like
the fact that this pawn on e5 and this
pawn on d4 controls more of the center
more of the space than black I like the
idea that this pawn on e5 controls these
two outposts squared d6 square f6 I like
the fact that this pawn on d4 controls
Square c5 so I begin to think in my
simplified imagination that gosh it
would really behoove me to put the
knight on any of these three squares
there would be protected squares they
would be attacking blacks camp it's
strange I'm looking at the position and
I think to myself my goodness look at
this I noticed that my pawns the white
pawns are d4 and d5 don't they block in
my dark-squared bishop wouldn't it make
sense that if i could follow it up like
this i would want to exchange to trade
my dark square bishop because I know
that with my pawns on e5 and d4 my
bishop could become a bad patient or
somewhat passive bishop and look at from
the black site black point of view and I
said well where are my outpost I'm black
I've got to have something going for me
it can't all be bad well I look and I
say f5 ideal square e for ideal square C
for ideal square I'm also tempted by
another thought I kind of think to
myself well wouldn't this be cool if I
were black and I could play the move
f7 f6 attacking this pawn on e5 I would
make a trade one day and in the
resulting position I would have a
protected passed pawn hey that's pretty
cool that's maybe something I could
aspire towards I I kind of like that
idea so suddenly this idea of f7 f6
starts to be a consideration that I want
to keep in mind also from blacks point
of view I think to myself oh my goodness
if what I've said about whites dark
square Bishop is true then it must be
doubly true for blacks LightSquared
bishop that in fact the pawns on e6 and
d5 are constricting me and I might have
trouble one day
playing with the light square bishop it
might behoove me to perhaps consider a
line like b7 b6 and Bishop a6 in order
to trade light squared bishop or maybe I
should consider a maneuver like Queen b6
Bishop here and Bishop here again with a
similar idea
trading like square bishops so in other
words I just think about the pawn
structure and try in my simplified
imagination to construct plans as
Michael pointed out I might even
consider that in a position like this
wouldn't it make a great deal of sense
for me to play a move like c5 c4 I would
gain space on the Queen side and maybe I
could follow it up with move B 5 B 4 and
so forth and so on in other words I look
at the position from the skeletal point
of view we're going to go back and
imagine another popular structure today
c5 becomes one of the most popular
defences the Sicilian defense and one of
the most popular structures for black in
the Sicilian defense it's kind of what
is called Scheveningen asha Vanagon pawn
structure and it looks like this from
blacks point of view with or without the
move eight seven a six doesn't really
matter but we get a structure like this
D 6 e 6 3 nice guys efore 3 nice guys 3
nice guys and again I start trying to
construct nice ideas from both sides
well the first thing I identify from
blacks point of view is he's got this
half open C file it's half open C file
it makes a great deal of sense to my
mind that I'm going to play rook e8 c8
quite quickly and after playing rook
AHCA the consequence might be to
sacrifice an exchange against c3 capture
pawn on e4 from White's point of view
white sees this pawn on d76
and hey wait a minute it's a potential
weakness first of all there's a
half-open D file from whites point of
view it makes a great deal of sense for
white to play rook on a1 to d1 and maybe
with moves like Knight b5 or even Bishop
f4 to target the pawn on d76 in other
words I'm just looking from a skeletal
point of view what plans might develop
from the pawn structure from this
particular pawn structure I consider
what are the outposts can somebody tell
me what blacks outpost for his knight
might be
Oh exactly
I mean it's very often they're very very
often black dust trying to fianchetto
his bishop both bishops in fact somehow
get fianchetto in classical Siobhan
Egan's but the question I was asking
it's just from blacks point of view from
his pawn structure
what are his outposts for his knights
Julian be fine c5 that's right
but you were reluctant with
understandable reason to suggest he 5
and C 5 C 5 you could have suggested
right away that that would be a very
reasonable outpost indeed for a knight
and you do in fact see the knight coming
very often to c5 you are a little bit
reluctant to say e 5 possibly probably
because she felt that it wasn't a real
outpost as there's always this F 2 F 4
move that could kick your knight back
from White's point of view what's a
natural outpost for whites Knights
well remarkably it isn't one I mean at
least in the direct term when we look at
the pawn on e4 we say the natural
outpost for the Knights are f5 and d5
the wait a minute there's neither square
is available so suddenly to win to win
controls of those squares we have to
conceive that a likely idea will be f4
f5 why because we want to provoke the
pawn to e5 so that we could take
possession of the d5 square or because
this night being on d4
putting pressure on the six pawn we
might want to follow it up with Bishop
c4 so again whatever opening whatever
defense that you conceive take a look
from the skeletal point of view now at
this point I would like somebody to give
me a very consequent line in any opening
give me a shot Spencer
pick your favorite defense is black
against one d4 what's your favorite
defense wonderful so we're gonna look at
a King's Indian so when we think about
or at least when I think about a Kings
Indian defense structure
what I'm really imagining in my mind is
a structure that looks like this with or
without the pawn on f5 but this to me
really does typify the Kings Indian
defense structure okay so once we've
decided that hey we're gonna choose the
Kings Indian defense well let's get
familiar with some of the ideas if we
again we take all eight pieces off the
board we just start to think and again
from my point of view as white will
start with white let's say I start to
think that structurally I I see these
one marvelous pawns here I control the
center I have space I see that this pawn
is especially reaching into blacks
position I don't really have a natural
outpost for a knife perhaps perhaps the
be five square
keeping in mind c7 c6
sure yeah yeah but before I even worry
about where my night where the nights go
from the opening moves I'm trying to
think conceptually of what my strategy
might be one of the things I'm attracted
to is I'm attracted to the fact that
this pawn on c4 in this pawn on d5
actually control a lot of space and I
started being attracted to the
opportunity to play c4 c5 okay and if I
gun so to speak for this move c4 c5 in
the first place this could lead
potentially to the opening of the C file
so I start to think that boy I sure like
to put a rock on C on the C file also
again we just start to think about the
structure and we say well doesn't this
structure inhibit our Bishop on f1 there
we go yeah yeah it actually does so that
mo c4 c5 starts to get even more and
more attractive if I could get in the
spawn to c5 by Bishop might get active
and and things might happen I also start
to think that woman should I play the
move F to F for and I'm a little bit
dismayed by that because I think that if
I if I play f4 and he captures haven't I
given black an ideal square on e5 blacks
point of view from blacks point of view
his outposts are obvious d4 and f4 I
mean and how many times in actuality or
Kings Indian defense players have played
Knights two squares d4 and f4 we might
also say that this bishop has the
potential of being passive thanks to
these blocking blockading pawns f7 f5 is
a natural natural advancement of the
pawn to try to attack white in the
center
and this is the way that I conceived or
chose my openings one of the things that
I really really was looking for an
opening was a lock structure or in other
words a fixed structure because I
thought thick structures were the
easiest ones to understand so if we go
back for example to my mind a Queens
gambit declined was a wonderful example
of a beautiful kind of fixed structure
that I could really sink my teeth into
so we're just going to set up a typical
position in the Queens gambit declined
okay so we just set up this position and
it really seemed to me that I got a very
good idea flavor of the strategies that
were going on here for both sides I
thought that thanks to the half-open C
file it was quite self-evident to me at
least that White's rook was going to go
to c1 that this idea of a minority to
attack with b4 and b5 made perfect sense
to try to create a weakness on the c6
square I also liked ideas for white that
had the knight jumping to ePHI you put
the knight on e5 you put your pawn on f4
your castle and then you do the old rook
left all of these made perfect sense I
was really really surprised when later
we discovered that this idea of 95 + f4
even had its own name you know the name
for the idea the Philidor attack
Philidor attack you go 95 f4 rook F
castles rook f3 and so but that all
seemed very natural to me when I was
looking
from the openings from the skeletal
point of view blacks point of view well
he has the half-open efile for his rook
it seems to me that the rook is going to
go to e8 you've got the e4 square under
control thanks to the night the knight
would jump to e4 and maybe this bishop
would he once the knight was on e4 this
bishop would go to a5 or g4 this Knight
is a little bit strange on the one hand
it might want to go to d7 to b6 because
after all this is also an outpost or if
we imagine that the rook was on e eight
we could imagine the knight going to f8
into g6 this was it was very similar to
say in the Spanish rule elope as where
white is forever going Knight d2 F 1 to
g3 well here it's rook e8 and the knight
going to g6 so I began to just form
plans ideas and tactics that were based
on the pawn structure I want to say when
I was very young it was much much easier
for me to play openings and defenses
that were based on thick structures such
as the French conversely it was very
very difficult to master or become an
expert in openings or defenses that the
pawn structure was really really fluid
or dynamic so let's see for example
about what I mean by a dynamic structure
ok imagine that we have a favorite
defense as black and we're gonna call
this defense the Perk defense
because that's what it's called so the
perk defense so he got a defense like
this and as black I thought this was a
very very difficult defense to master
although I tried my hardest because in
fact is really a large dynamic number of
possibilities here for white for example
one of the most aggressive and dynamic
possibilities is what you might think of
as a three pawn or attack which is
called in fact the Austrian attack and
after Bishop g7 nine of three c5 d c5
Queen a5 isn't this is a massive massive
amount of analysis in this line or the
line castles D 597 H 4 C 5 H 5 takes
this is like another massive variation
full of analysis many many hundreds of
games have gone like this White's going
all-out for the attack on blacks King
and again as black you have to know if
you're going to play the perk defense
you have to have an idea of how you're
going to meet all of these various
approaches another approach that one
fellow played against me it's just to
play f2 f3
tassels Bishop III which is a very very
different approach for white one of
White's ideas is to go Queen d2 castles
long and g4 g5 another variation I've
had to face this is a kind of a very
much in your face variation g6 h4 I mean
talk about wanting to kill me right
right out of the bat Bishop g7 h5 I go
for it baby Knight takes Knight takes h5
rook takes h5 g takes h5 just
sacrificing in the exchange to go after
white just sacrifices an exchange and
just plays the position that's quite an
approach another approach I mean there's
just so many approaches that white can
choose another approach that has been
tried against me is g6 Bishop e2 Bishop
g7 g4 oh yeah if the Chinese attack is
what a Chinese player in the 1978
Olympiad did against Grand Master Yi on
hind Donner just went Bishop e2 g4 I
have played against a lot coke
Ivanovitch as Black Sea v g5 97 d5 which
is very benoni ish in its flavor so this
defense the perk defense to my mind
really required a great deal of
knowledge because the pawn structure the
pawn structure was so fluid is so
dynamic for those of you play the ala
kind offense you never know what kind of
person it seems to me at least you never
know what kind of pawn structure you're
going to
Alekhine and you're different your your
your defense has to be very adaptable
for again for example against the
alaka'i it seems to me white has choices
such as bees right hon takes for example
this is a variation
I mean trades trades a very very
different unusual pawn structure on the
one hand you might be very happy to have
light to very beautiful sets of pawns
three and three black has three pawn
islands these three guys these two guys
and this eyelid isolated pawn represent
three different pawn islands I mean but
very unusual on structure in the ILA
kind defense we just go back back back
far more common for the alekhina knee is
e v 9d 5d 4d 6 now here white might try
something as simple as c4 Knight b6
trade pawns like this so we get one kind
of pawn structure turn me trade pawns
like this takes takes so we get a very
symmetrical balance kind of pawn
structure or we might get a pawn
structure like this
dock dock and in this kind of pond
structure the black has to be always
very careful that a d4 d5 doesn't blow
you out of the water so in a sense what
I'm saying is you can bring your
openings you're as white and as black
down to two types of openings dynamic
pawn structures or locked or simplified
pawn structures this strikes me is a
very very dynamic pawn structure with
lots of you might get overwhelmed trying
to tell me you know what are the
strengths the multiple strengths and the
multiple weaknesses of both players
positions I mean if you're just a dove
say well I like this advantage this
simple advantage for white I like this
simple thing for black but then you keep
adding and adding and adding to your
list Michael had a question yeah no I
well first of all yes there used to be
an entire classical school that chess
thought that said you know there's open
positions and there's closed positions
but actually it's not really that simple
for example a closed position was widely
thought as any position that just simply
both sides had eight pawns well it was
closed but was it really if the pawns
were locked up it still wasn't closed
because one guy might be going for one
type of lower the other guy for another
what do you do about positions where
there's a pair of pawns traded is that
an open position or does an open
position only describe a situation where
two pairs of pawns have been traded and
hence the position is quote wide open or
merely open so as opposed to the
distinctions and
trying to find a definition of proper
definition of a closed or locked I just
went for the dynamic structure versus
but not so dynamic this structure
strikes me is very very dynamic this
structure conversely a French defense
lock structure was not very dynamic it
was locked it was closed so that was the
distinction I was making to further the
point if you're a very very very
aggressive player and you needed to win
lots and lots of games you had a very
high rating that you wanted to protect
by being a decisive killer at the
chessboard you had a 2,500 rating and
you were playing a lot of 2,100 2,200
2,300 players you needed to win a lot of
the games guess what you're playing
dynamic openings because it was
incumbent upon you to win minigames to
protect your rating conversely if you
were like I said taking up chest
learning chess just trying to just
trying to hang in there so to speak keep
your feet dry you wanted to play locked
static simplified pawn structures
because it was so very easy to
understand the underlying ideas the
strategic principles so we go back to
where I started the lecture mr. Sarah
mr. Sarah won how do I get better at
chess now we start to understand how
difficult it is for me to answer the
question
what's your rating are you trying to
play dynamically have you played
dynamically have you played statically
do you understand the ideas do you do
you talk to the skeletons in your
position do you know all the skeletons
in your closet you know do you know what
the skeletons are trying to tell you
and so we go from there a moment ago I
asked Spencer to give me one of his
favorite defense it says and he called
out the Kings India so let's go and go a
little bit deeper into the Kings Indian
so you can get a better idea of how I
approached the Kings India
so if Spencer says to me yes
tonight I'm gonna play the Kings Indian
and I'm playing to kick your butt I go
okay I get it I mean this is you want to
play rough you want to play rough okay
well if we're gonna play rough Spencer
and I I'm gonna bring out my a-game and
for me the a game has always been the
same issue variation I have a lot of pet
lines that I like to play against the
Kings Indian I played Bishop e2 Bishop
g5 my absolute favorite is Bishop d3
almost kind of a Sarah one system I
played it so often but the same ish has
always been one of my favorites now in
this position and the same issue it's
very clear what my intention is thanks
to my pawn being on f3 I want to put my
Bishop on e3 and I don't want to be
bothered no Knight g4 but it's cost me a
tempo to fortify my Center
now black actually remarkably enough has
a wide variety of ways of meeting the
same ish he can play four lines with c5
he can play four lines with E 5 and
surprisingly enough he can play c6 a6
and b5 Spence your choice what do you do
against the same ish
okay so knight c6 Bishop III Castle
excellent decision excellent I always
say you know like Kings nice and
protected
excellent decision castles so I'm an old
pond grubber so I'm gonna try to play a
line of the same ish that in the great
words of international master Nikolai
Manette gift made upon so I'm going to
play Knight on G to E - do you play with
a 6 ok so after a 6 I'm going to play
Knight c1 do you play with rook b8 yes
Ruby 8 and so what
Spencer's idea with this whole little
demonstration on the Queen side is what
he wants to do is actually keep things
fluid in the center notice that in a
king's indian e7 e 5 is the most common
move but he's deliberately held back
it's like he said you know before I
commit myself in the center I'm going to
do some things on the Queen side that
might prove effective and I'm saying
they're saying well from my point of
view I've built up my Center yeah and
remember what I was saying about this
bishop I'm oftentimes I'm looking
forward to the opportunity playing c4 c5
so that I can bring my bishop here so
dispense your choice Bishop to d7 and
now I make the quiet move Queen d2
correct so after that we gonna go back
maybe here I think have you castled
yeah okay so in this position and have I
done it right okay so the standard move
as Spence is now recalling is that he's
supposed to play e5 I play d5 correct 94
so as I was explaining to this class I'm
an old pawn grubber so I want first of
all I want very very much for black to
capture this night so that I could
capture with a pawn and that makes it
much easier for me to play b4 b5 the
standard move is c5 would you like to
try it or yes so the standard move is c5
and if we look at that position it's
self-evident that knight on d4 is also
we can't allow that
so I capture on Poisson and if you
capture with a knight you have regrets
you have regrets because you have a
backward pawn on d6 that is after I will
play Queen d2
I'll put pressure it's much more common
for you to capture and this is where you
have boldly sacrifice upon for what
we're not sure yet
but black well these sacrifices upon now
here as far as I understand you have
three moves rook b8 Bishop e6 for most
rook b8 Bishop e6 rook e8 and d65
yeah exactly and I think you didn't know
that that you were following a long long
long long stein exactly it this that I
think that's very very important what
just slipped out there oftentimes you
just play an opening because it felt
right that's all you just had a good
feeling about your position and it felt
right so a move like d65 feels right I
mean it's just like well that's the good
move okay so here there's a couple of
things that I could do one I can take
the pawn on d5 you would presumably
recapture if I capture this knight on f6
and let's say you recapture with the
Queen I play Knight takes d5 Queen takes
b2 that just feels like with the dark
square Bishop sand and a safe King
you're doing fine
so the standard move from whites point
of view is e4 e5 standard move from
blacks point of view it's Knight d7 you
can play rook e8 if you want I don't
think it makes too much of a difference
although I can't absolutely be sure of
that but okay very good
rook e8 Bishop e2 we should be two now
by the way I'm still upon up I'm
dreaming in my happy fantasy world that
I'm going to play f4 and castles and
coast my way to a gorgeous stunning
victory that's exactly Knight H Phi is a
very standard move I Castle
so aha that's a very good point so you
started to think that if you play Bishop
takes e5 Bishop takes e5 rook takes e5
and recapture your pawn an extremely
good idea I might add
then after move like f4 attacking your
rook this night on h5 and we have issues
so rather than capture the pawn and
especially is not to allow to move f4
Knight f4 so I say go back and I keep my
pawn now you have two choices I don't
really like the move Knight h3 check it
feels a little bit artificial and flaky
after for example King h1 f4 there's a
possibility the knight is simply badly
placed you could go for Knight takes
eetu Queen takes e to and struggle to
regain your pawn you could go for Knight
b6 to capture my bishop and capture the
pawn so a lot of choices
precisely so so you take my bishop
now here funnily enough I could go for a
different kind of a battle right these
things these are the things that I kind
of go through my mind as I think about
the opening another kind of a battle I
might go for is Knight takes Bishop
takes Bishop takes rook takes Knight d4
and then conceptually I say oh I've got
a knight on d4 against the passive more
or less passive bishop but I'm an old
pond rubber I believe in material so
gift me de Pape gift Mead upon well
that's been a long Leviev in the case
for a long long time so one of the
things that should be going through
blacks mind is he could consider a line
like Bishop takes Bishop takes f6 then
Bishop takes f6 and oops that's a
tactical accident okay so what about the
move f7 f6 and let's just imagine these
two moves being played with or without
Bishop h3 it doesn't matter now when we
made the decision to play f7 f6f for
trade the pawns on e5 something should
be going through our mind a certain
realization what are we doing we're
opening up the F file is that good or
bad
well the answer yeah for white excellent
for white weak well yeah but but it's
white whose rook is on the F file so we
open up the position against ourselves
so I don't know if that it maybe Spence
you want to toss in Bishop h3 before f6
or you had another
idea yeah exactly
okay rook e8 to toss that one into the
mix very very natural now I don't know
should I play a3 should I play b3 should
I even bother I'm not sure but one thing
I am sure about I do want to have the
pawn on f4 I mean if I'm going to keep
my extra pawn I'm going to commit myself
I'm going to play F for one day and so
that's a move that that fits with the
position how we assess this position
that's a different manner
maybe black is very very happy because
he has two bishops and a safe King
White's King there are some light square
weaknesses over there so it's not a cut
and dry deal that this is all good for
white but these are the ways that I
would look at the Kings and I would look
at the Kings inning I would fight my way
through and I would really look at it as
from the point of view of structure like
I am very very happy oh praise be the
Lord
I'm upon up very very happy about the
extra pawn but equally I'm actually very
happy that you have a pawn on d5 not
because I really want to take it but
really because if this pawn were gone I
would be a little bit right so in in one
way I might say long time in the future
this pawn on d5 is a weakness but for
the moment I'm really glad that you that
it's on the board and it's in hinging
the power of the light square bishop and
this is the way I would walk myself
through openings and it there's such a
if you guys are you guys familiar with
encyclopedia of chess openings the five
volume series version ones twos and
threes
I mean there's tens of thousands tens of
thousands of openings and defenses and
how how how are you going to determine
which one suits you or not you don't
have you can't give a half-an-hour to
each and every one I mean then you're 50
years old so you have to somehow cut cut
and and make short cuts the openings and
defenses that you choose and that was
how I did it I was looking at from
structures and what structures I felt
suited me for example I felt very suited
to the French defense structure because
it was very easy simple for me to
understand and I knew where my pieces
went other people you know different
ideas for me I liked the English opening
that was one c4 can I have another
give me another opening and defense and
we can just go through it very quickly
as to how I would approach it mad
what's your favorite defense to 1.e4
okay very good this is an excellent
excellent also one thing that I think a
lot of people have to understand about
openings his openings are better for
fashion statement they they there's
suddenly it's like everybody and his
brother and sister are happily playing a
particular opening or a defense and then
it's like the very next day it's out of
style out of fashion when I was a kid
the Scandinavia I mean what kid didn't
start playing chess without you know
knowing the Scandinavian and then it
just kind of like I don't know if it's a
level of maturity if if it kind of just
simply fell out of favor the
Scandinavian but I really don't know
what
wrong with the Scandinavian defense I
think it's a very good opening for black
and so much so so I'm sitting there
going I was in 1990 1995 I beg your
pardon
I am in New York the World Trade Towers
I'm like on the hundred and tenth floor
and it's the match
Kasparov white an on black and Kasparov
is just playing
efore to win you know he's got it plays
efore and this you just rolls out the
Scandinavian defense with defy and draws
very simply with black so I mean if
Garry Kasparov
doesn't have a refutation to the
Scandinavian defense and why is it not
more popular today well maybe a question
of fashion so after a takes d5 you
actually have two major choices one is
Knight f6 and one is Queen D I assume
you would follow up with the Queen d5
line yeah okay so Queen takes d5 so
Knight c3 and basically everybody in
this brother plays Queen a5 or Queen d6
or Queen d8 amen oh sure we'll come back
to that
so essentially let's just go with Queen
a5 for the moment let's go with d4 let's
go with Knight f6 and we're getting
close to a near tabia position of the
Scandinavian now here black has to make
some critical choices does he want to
castle long does he want to castle long
should he play lines with Bishop g4
knight c6 and castles long which are
very very sharp yeah should he play
lines that are solid with c7 c6 Bishop
g4 eise evany six and it's almost a
caro-kann like structure where whites
night instead of being saying on the
square g3 is on the square c3 your
choice
how do you go knight c6 yes pawn c6 is
your choice I beg your pardon
and I'm yes sure before the move c6
exactly exactly and I think that that's
a that's a major choice in this position
is to play Bishop g4 with the idea of
accelerating your play by bringing your
rook to d8 putting pressure on the d4
pawn and it's not everybody's choice
because the the comp the the lines are
very very sharp perhaps you have some
experience with that sorry so c7 c6 and
then if I recall
doesn't everybody play Bishop c4 or
Bishop d2 here right and then do you
like to play the line with Bishop g4
Bishop f5 yes exactly it's okay I mean
that this is your line your defense okay
and now how do you meet h2 h3 you take
the knight okay
which is fine everything is fine takes
takes
I assume you're playing quit ninety
seven or six okay so now actually from
Matt's point of view Matt plays this as
a as a choice and I think it's a very
easy choice he can live with so the
first thing we do is we kind of take a
look at the structure and we say well
these two pawns being on e6 and c6 it's
a real good thing we trade off
LightSquared bishop like we don't have
to worry about it anymore
secondly we can say that the pawn on d4
gives white a space edge power to him
gives him control of the e5 and c5
squares but what the knight on c3 it's
not gonna be that easy for white to
bring his Knights to those outposts from
blacks point of view he's got a great
outpost sitting here on d5 it's just
beckoning so moves like 97 96 Bishop
before going for control of the d5
square just to natural we can just
expect these types of things not
everybody's cup of tea but why should be
happy as a head the two bishops we do
consider this a kind of a plus but this
is the type of structure by the way that
I really like to play even today because
I find the ideas so easy I'm not gonna
be shocked I mean there's not gonna be
some surprising move that wipes me out
yeah and I think your results are are
you happy with your results yeah yeah
which is very good and that's really
also the other thing too is specializing
there comes times in your chess cycle
your skills that you want to specialize
first of all you want to specialize and
really really you know your opening and
your defense inside and out so you
really feel confident when you come to
the board that you're not just gonna be
you're not going to be surprised so it's
very very good to specialize then later
after you reach a real mature level of
scale you just you discover that
sometimes you've fallen into a rut and
your game has become apathetic you're
not but you're not growing you're not
challenging yourself enough it's sort of
like you've you you've mastered one
thing and you don't want to move from it
that's the only thing you're interested
and so you have to change your openings
for other reasons but before you before
all of that happens of course I suggest
specializing and in this case power to
you Matt you found a specialty
the Scandinavian that I think is
actually very reasonable and decent
option any questions have overwhelmed
you
yes night 8:00 at night of six oh sure
sure okay sir
so the first point is black has to be
already very careful with his move order
okay so night F D for no hold on Queen
takes Knight here Queen at d4 Knight f6
Knight f3
okay so white black already has to be
very careful with his move order for
example it would have missed be a
mistake to play knight c6 here because
d5 comes with a tempo the knight is
going to have to move Knight takes d5
Queen takes d5 as a showstopper and I
can't jump here here the knight would
have to come to be safe before Bishop
check is a very unpleasant check c7 c6
doesn't get as the variation so we have
to go back and we have to say okay in
this position Bishop g4 so we can't play
knight c6 now however we're thinking to
ourselves we're ready to play knight c6
and castles because we don't worry about
d4 d5 okay so I was black I think
against Michael Road and he played h3
now I didn't take math choice to heart I
could take the knight Queen takes and I
think after a move like c7 c6 kind of
transpose to what you did
Mya thought I went here yeah and now
what did Michael do I think Michael went
here
Bishop c4 now here I didn't try knight
c6 I think I played the movie 76
I played easy I think this had a problem
g4 then d5 something like that I know
that there's a tactical problem so I
went even a 6
he went g4 I went Bishop here
and he went 95 95 I'm having trouble
remembering the line it was it was a
very long time ago Queen e2 now on the
one hand I was very happy with the black
pieces because I have provoked my
opponent into ultra aggression mode and
he's advanced these pawns and I'm very
hopeful hopeful that one in the future
they're going to prove a weakness in the
source of counter play for me and two it
really means that I now have a good
guess about the address of the White
King and it's not going to go King side
because the pawn shield has been
weakened but rather is going to go Queen
side all brilliant of course but I still
failed horribly in laws like a child
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]